oh
as the use of radioactive materials
increases
the problems associated with the
disposal of the waste become ever more
important
of all known toxic materials radioactive
nuclides alone cannot be detoxified or
rendered harmless by any known chemical
or physical processing
safe disposal of these materials
requires that they be so segregated that
any return to man is in such a low
concentration has to be certainly
harmless
all manner of possible return paths must
be considered in choosing a processing
and disposal method
disposal by burial on land requires the
utmost care to ensure that there is a
negligible contact between the waste
product and water sources through which
the isotopes might return to man either
directly or through food chains
when intermediate products such as
edible plants animals and fish are
involved the effects of biological
concentrations of particular nuclides in
these intermediates must be carefully
appraised
the most common radioactive waste
problems concern the relatively small
user of isotopes obtained primarily from
nuclear reactors
the high level wastes originating from
reactor operation itself and the
associated chemical processing requires
special handling at the installations
where the wastes originate
the national institutes of health is an
organization devoted to research in
clinical medicine and the associated
basic sciences
some 500 members of the scientific staff
use about 100 curies of radioactive
isotopes each year
because of the biological emphasis of
the research program
carbon 14 and hydrogen 3 or tritium are
the most commonly used nuclides
waste disposal methods must take into
account the particular properties of
these isotopes
at the national institutes of health the
radiation safety office is the
organization responsible for all
radiation safety operations
these operations include the processing
and disposal of radioactive wastes
safety office functions center around
the isotope laboratory located apart
from other laboratories and service
buildings
the disposal methods to be shown are the
result of over 10 years of development
in cooperation with the united states
coast guard
the deep sea was chosen as the most
desirable ultimate depository
burial at sea must be carried out so
there will be no interference with
either commercial or sport fishing
no significant concentrations of any
isotope deposited must appear at the
surface of the sea or on any beach
the waste disposal area approximately
ninety miles due east of norfolk is over
one thousand fathoms in depth
radioactive waste processing and
packaging is carried out in a restricted
area near the isotope laboratory
this area is surrounded by a custodial
fence to separate it from the activities
and traffic of the institutes
radioactive wastes must be classified
into several different types and the
disposal governed accordingly
here a chemical experiment is
originating wastes of varying levels of
activity
samples are being pipetted out for
measuring preparatory to initiating the
proper disposal procedures
these liquid wastes will be assorted
depending upon the level of activity as
measured with the portable survey meter
carefully measured samples are placed in
the counting planchets to obtain a
standardized volume for checking with
the scintillation counter all of these
manipulations take place inside a hood
with absorbing paper underneath
materials so that spills can be readily
discarded
the waste of low activity will be
disposed of directly into the regular
sewer system with water flushing the
sample down the drain at the disposal
time
this other waste which was found to
contain somewhat greater activity will
be put into a special sewer system
this leads to a large underground
retention tank where the waste will be
held for an appreciable length of time
before being released to the municipal
sewer system
both of these wastes are short half-life
or else disposal by either of these
means would not be allowable
waste containing carbon 14 or tritium
cannot be classified by the crude assay
method previously shown
with these weak beta emitters carefully
prepared samples are counted in a liquid
scintillator
the scintillating solution and the
photomultiplier tubes picking up the
tiny flashes of light are kept at a very
low temperature in a deep freeze to
reduce the effect of extraneous
disturbances on the electric circuits
carbon 14 and tritium wastes that are
too concentrated for direct disposal
will be kept for burial at sea
each of these nuclides has a half-life
that is too long for appreciable decay
to occur during any practical storage
period
patient treatment areas generate large
quantities of contaminated articles with
bed linens and outstanding examples
wherever possible patients receiving
radioisotopes handle their own urine
collections in the treatment areas
urines containing gamma emitters are
kept in heavily shielded containers and
are collected at frequent intervals
another source of active waste material
comes from animal experiments this
animal has been injected with a long
lived radioactive material
note that the experimenters are wearing
rubber gloves to avoid contamination of
hands
blood samples are withdrawn placed into
counting planchets for drying and
subsequent assay
marking tape is used whenever
radioactive material is involved it is
most important that all packages be so
marked and an approximate value given of
the amount of the isotope present and
the isotope identified
animal carcasses are stored at low
temperature until ready for disposal by
approved methods
since licenses for radioactive materials
are given by possession limits it is
necessary to keep a careful account of
the isotopes that are thrown away
each package must be marked with the
amount of the isotope which it contains
throughout all waste disposal operations
and processing
accurate records are kept of radiation
exposure of all personnel involved
film badge monitoring devices are loaded
and prepared for issue throughout the
institutes
a most important part of the monitoring
consists of keeping records
most of these records will be needed
perhaps five to ten years after they
have been entered
so neatness accuracy and legibility are
most important items in the record
keeping
records must be kept of all radioactive
waste materials that are disposed of by
whatever means
this represents about one half of a
day's collection from the laboratories
and clinical areas at the institute
delivery of radioactive materials to the
radiation safety office is made so easy
that there will be little or no
temptation to dispose of these materials
by other methods
otherwise these radioactive materials
might be found in the regular trash
containers or dumped indiscriminately
into the municipal sewer system
the polyethylene bags are the liners of
the waste containers which are handed
out to all users of active materials
wastes are classified and records kept
of each package its location and the
method of final disposal
here materials of short half-life are
being kept for decay and for later
incineration
materials which have too long a
half-life to allow decay to take place
will be put into children size concrete
burial vaults for ultimate disposal at
sea
liquids solids and activities of many
different levels are some of the diverse
materials which are collected
vaults are standard commercially
available containers of convenient size
they are made of steel reinforced
concrete and have lifting eyes cast into
the bottom
short lengths of steel cable are
attached to these eyes for handling
the vaults are packed as carefully as
possible to include a maximum amount of
material
this cuts down the number of containers
required and aids in obtaining the
density required to ensure sinking in
the ocean
special waste products require special
methods of handling
here are the steps that lead to the
ultimate disposal of some cobalt pellets
they have already been packaged in lead
and welded into a steel pipe
spacing rings encircle the cobalt
container so that the pipe will be
centered into the steel disposal drum
the drum will then be filled with
concrete although there is some gamma
ray activity at the surface of the steel
container the handling is done without
intervening shields because of the
relatively short time involved
observe how the centering devices help
as the pipe is lowered into the drum
note the marking of the drum to indicate
that it now contains radioactive
materials the amount and isotope being
marked on the label
a wet concrete mortar is now poured
around the steel container containing
the cobalt pellets the concrete in this
particular case fills the drum readily
without any tapping and a solid mass
will result without any agitation
the concrete can be mixed to any desired
consistency
the steel pipe is suspended from the top
of the drum to prevent it sinking
through the soft mass before the
concrete hardens
an immediate check is made of the
surface gamma activity of the container
this is to make sure that it will comply
with all of the interstate commerce
regulations governing the shipment of
radioactive materials over state
highways
the markings on the drums are made in
accordance with requirements of aec
licensing
they cover the amount and the isotope
contained therein
also identifying marks so that if there
is any future recovery the origin of the
drum can be identified
waste materials are packed in the
concrete burial vaults and mixed
intimately with a thin concrete mortar
all of the polyethylene containers are
broken to ensure an intimate mix with
the concrete and also to obtain a
maximum density to ensure sinking in the
ocean
vaults are shallow enough to permit good
mixing of the contents with thin
concrete
the safety office personnel working
directly over the vaults wear
respirators to prevent the inhalation of
airborne radioactive materials
this is not considered necessary for the
cement workers who have a casual contact
and are not working directly over the
vault during the active braking of the
polyethylene containers
the vaults are actively agitated during
the entire filling operation to
eliminate voids and obtain as intimate
mixing as possible
actual tests show that the finished
containers remain intact under the
hydrostatic pressures at depths of at
least six thousand feet
vacuum pumps used on a radon plant are
contaminated to an extent where
decontamination would be more expensive
than replacement
so they are disposed of along with other
types of wastes
this is a sample of the wastes collected
at an institution such as the national
institutes of health
the vaults are finally sealed with a few
inches of richer cement mix than is used
in the body of the filling
these vaults shown here represent about
one day's processing and contain
approximately six months waste supply
from the institutes
upon completion they are checked for
gross gamma activity with the gamma
sensitive meter
each vault must be marked with
identifying symbols to show the isotope
contained therein the approximate amount
the authorization permits under which
shipment is made and marks and dates for
nih identification purposes
the radioactive materials contained in
these vaults are considered to be class
d poisons and therefore require the use
of interstate commerce commission labels
as well as direct identification as
radioactive materials
the new concrete surfaces are painted to
reduce moisture absorption while
awaiting final disposition
the finished vaults are now checked to
be sure there is no surface
contamination
this is done by making a series of wipes
across the surface of the finished
concrete
these wipes are then counted in a gas
flow counter this is required because of
the possible presence of either carbon
14 or tritium both of which are beta
emitters
an automatic counter is used each wipe
be encountered for a preset number of
counts with the time required being
recorded on a paper tape
if the counts are within prescribed
limits essentially zero
the vaults can then be handled without
gloves from here on
if positive contamination is found on
the surface it will be removed by
scrubbing or by covering the contaminant
with a heavy coat of paint or some other
covering material
upon completion of the counts the
counting rate is carefully noted and
becomes a part of the record of each
finished container
as the vaults are made ready for loading
into trucks for transportation to the
port of embarkation a final gamma check
is made on each individual vault to be
sure that it fulfills the requirements
for transportation over public roads
each truck is loaded so that very low
activity balls for those containing only
non-penetrating beta emitters are placed
next to the driver
this provides additional shielding
between him and any vaults which show an
appreciable gamma activity at the
surface
this precaution is perhaps unnecessary
but is carried out simply because any
radioactive exposure should be avoided
whenever possible
each convoy is accompanied by a trained
monitor in a separate vehicle carrying
monitoring instruments capable of making
measurements at any radioactive
emergency which may arise during the
shipment
the truck convoy leaving for the port of
embarkation must comply with a variety
of regulations
weight and vehicle spacings while
underway are prescribed by state law
the trucks pulling into an official
state weighing station have red lights
flashing merely to indicate a turn off
the main highway
the lights are not a part of the
procedures associated with the shipment
of the radioactive materials
truck loadings are made with due regard
for the loads allowed by state
regulations each finished vault weighs
about 1500 pounds in air
each shipment will have a total weight
of 20 to 30 tons
after weights are checked the convoy
proceeds at all times following the
regulations required for convoys
proper spacing between vehicles is
maintained so that overtaking vehicles
need not pass the convoy as a unit but
can pull in between the trucks if
necessary
in general the convoying sedan follows
behind the last truck to take care of
any stragglers who may have mechanical
difficulties
the convoy ends at the coast guard base
in norfolk virginia where the waste
containers are loaded onto the fan tail
of the coast guard cutter
this vessel is equipped with steel trays
which prevent contact of the waste
container with the wooden deck and in
addition
raise the shipment to a level that will
clear the rail of the ship during the
dumping procedure
one of the larger trays shown here is
equipped with sections of roller
conveyors to facilitate the offloading
of the concrete vaults at the designated
dumping site
the steel platform is for handling the
steel drums
each set of concrete vaults is locked in
position by a special locking device
which can be tripped at sea for the safe
release of the containers
as in the case of loading the trucks
preferences given to those vaults
showing some gamma activity at the
surface by placing them out board and
away from the positions which will be
occupied by the crew during the normal
working of the vessel
it will be noted that here the crew
members are handling the vaults without
protective gloves because of the
previous checks which have shown the
surfaces to be completely free of
radioactive contamination
before the trucks are released to return
to the institutes
a final check is made with a thin window
counter to be sure that no contamination
has been left in the truck bodies
when this has been so demonstrated the
signs are removed and the trucks are
available for regular duties without
restrictions
aboard ship steel drums are lashed down
to prevent movement during the voyage
out to the dumping ground
the hands and feet of the crew members
are checked to be sure that no
contamination has been received by any
of them in loading the vaults and drums
these surveys are conducted with a
geiger counter which will respond to
carbon 14 and more energetic emitters
but which will not detect tritium
with the thorough mixing of the wastes
it is hard to imagine a contamination of
tritium alone
and so an absence of activity is assumed
to indicate an absence of tritium also
tripping a dog releases four vaults
which go overside almost simultaneously
but without any damaging collisions
this is done at the dumping ground
prescribed in the waste disposal license
granted by the atomic energy commission
experiments conducted at depths of one
thousand fathoms or six thousand feet
suggest that about fifteen to twenty
minutes is required for containers to
reach the bottom
all materials are disposed of at a depth
of not less than one thousand fathoms
which in the norfolk area
means approximately eighty to ninety
miles due east to carry the ship beyond
the continental shelf
here the fedometer reading for one
particular trip
indicates that disposal is made at a
depth of one thousand fathoms
you